[Music]
in killer job news
submitted by serveth in parts parts
these are the top 10 most dangerous
special forces around the world how do
they know like Indian special forces all
around the world and [ __ ] what about the
US a crosswalk team ladies in the neon
vests they're pretty dangerous
neighborhood watch I always wanted to be
a part of the neighborhood watch because
I like that spy like coat with the
[ __ ] black - don't blow though yeah I
thought that was the uniform for the
main neighborhood watch but that was
actually the criminal regime the
neighborhood people walk around the
neighborhood watch people actually walk
her out I've never seen them walk around
they seen them once no they had like a
reflective vest and that's really about
it
are you sure wasn't a crosswalk er
walking to the station no that'll be
really weird at 2:00 or 3:00 a.m.
have you heard of the guardian angels in
New York so back in a day when New York
was full of like gangs like that
old-school movie warriors and [ __ ] and
their gangs had all these cool little
like styles and [ __ ] that wasn't all
like you know today where everyone's
copying each other yeah but like back
then there was this group where they
were red berets and they looked kind of
military but they were like a gang but
there were like neighborhood watch New
York New York and he brought that [ __ ]
back New York did that sounds pretty
cool well that organization they're
called the guardian angels some stuff
yep
are you gonna go in the list of the most
dangerous to know part start from the
not so dangerous or in no particular
order so the richest calm they created
this list and they started off from 10
all the way to the most the most most I
want to see that I wanna see at least
least dangerous special forces that
would be a good article which Special
Forces is always losing all
you know and always messing up missions
one this list the leaf dangerous but
you're still top ten in the world off
well in terms of this list the least
dangerous Special Forces is the GI GN
from France number ten
well cortisone like the least because
there's too busy drinking espresso but
there's at least of still the top ten
though there's still [ __ ] yeah yeah so
there's still like pretty much the cream
of the crop yeah oh so by the way what g
IG n stands for is yes you're not going
national
gender mere intervention group okay
that's what that means why they trying
to intervene within genders the next in
line number nine is the SSG from
pakistan that's for special services
group oceans in pakistan they look dull
maybe it's a river
damn pakistani ninjas dude that's pretty
dope damn how shitty is that little
badass when when the body of lettuce
right next to the water there's no
growth around it okay it's like a canyon
in water yeah
desert to water number 8 oz looses
cigarettes much Kyle sorry if I
mispronounced that from Israel Israeli
Special Forces damn they're hugging up
while they with the guns yeah that's
tight that's a group huddle that's like
the the race that you play at the park
during birthday parties where you tie
your [ __ ] legs together and you try
to stay and see that's teamwork right
there yeah now I'm wondering if all top
three are just All American forces oh we
might be surprising might not even be in
the top three I doubt that though we go
and train other special forces
number seven is EK o Cobra from Austria
I didn't even know Austria was still a
country what yeah yeah yeah Germany just
took everything why it is a mini Germany
though
there's really no difference I'm sorry
my I'm into both sorry I know I [ __ ]
up I'm just a stupid American Austrians
and Germans with Mexicans is different
you know it's crazy when you go to
Austria though they always have like mmm
merchandise that the they're like there
no kangaroos here cuz I guess people I
did in elementary school I said why
would you name a country so similar to
another country true messed up on the
branding there England
number six is Delta for us of a doctor
horse is number six dude Chuck Norris
what's Delta Force so Delta Force is
Army Special Forces and I thought there
would be top three I thought you were in
that I'm just kidding Special Forces but
it's just it's like the people in the
military they like to like talk [ __ ] and
be rifles kind of like like sports teams
they don't really mean [ __ ] because
people that are talking [ __ ] don't do
[ __ ] you know I mean like I was a Marine
but it's not like I'm [ __ ] yeah
because you know all the [ __ ] Lakers
but do you play basketball I played I
don't know but it's still fun to talk
[ __ ] yeah number five is the jtf2 from
Canada and what it says is Joint Task
Force
- oh that's cheating that's why TV so
joint task force means they got like
multiple branches and the cream of the
cream of the crop and put us again so
like Harlem Globetrotters that's not
fair
collab in order to get on this list
seven leaves are getting the best of the
best out of that yeah it wasn't like
that one sports it was like one from
each person that's like the USA dream
team of course if you grab LeBron and
you grab someone else from another team
like Chris Paul stuff what did he put
them together BAM of course it'll be a
good team come on I'm having I didn't
even know Canada had a military they do
because I mean like they're like the
least invasive like keep to themselves
just stay peaceful kind of people maybe
that's their [ __ ] like that's what they
really appear but then that's what keeps
them you know
I could be whatever I want really nice
the first time I ever went to Canada I
was in my hotel and two drunk
artillerists they came up to me and
they're like where are you from mother
I'm from you know whatever you know
United States alone well you're cutting
a drink with us the whole trick with
them for like five six hours went back
to my hotel yeah share me share with me
a whole bunch of beers I even put on my
Instagram it was pretty cool they're
really cool guys that's time till erases
though that's where they said their
artillery they do the their cannon boys
number four on this list is alpha group
oh my goodness
Sammy looks like a [ __ ] car of game
character doubles I got criminal I can
unlock yeah yeah criminal how come you
got a blue glove probably left it at
home if I gotta buy something last
minute I thought the Russian group was
called likes
Spets cat's nose or something oh that's
another one
well this list says well what about
spits yeah
and they write well to keep it simple
any list which gives vets Nance a
distinct force is just plain wrong as
that term is a general name for all
Soviet Russian Special Forces oh so just
say my Special Forces but it's not
really that exact unit or Department
yeah gotcha I did it no wonder how like
people feel with this came up I mean we
got to kill more people this you guys
know like hurts their feelings and [ __ ]
I've given many people I don't know what
you are talking about I think we deserve
six chicken women everybody know so now
we're at the top three no number three
is shayetet 13 from Israel another
Israeli force yeah this was a game how
many do they have
ah looks like a marine branch they look
like there would be really good at
fixing plumbing systems the sewers
overflowing send those guys in i watch
the documentary on these [ __ ]
dude and they get the cream of the crop
and that cream of the crop gets whittled
down to 2% of that yep what I mean the
crop within the Nate within the Navy
yeah yeah ah so for what Canada did is
like take like Delta Force Navy SEAL
Force Recon whatever Air Force
paratroopers and then one from each this
is still within the Navy I was watching
a documentary too and then one thing
that I was like meant that that made me
feel like they're really badass is
they're asking like what are you good at
any goes we're good at getting good goes
if you need a language learn by 4:00
a.m. tomorrow done oh I need to know a
building inside and out like the entire
ploop blueprint give me four hours done
they're like two minutes that's [ __ ]
crazy that is sexy because the thing
that I was watching it was like they
would follow a few select amount of
people that wanted to be a Navy SEAL
and they'd get selected out right and
then by the end of it the people that I
thought were gonna make it all the way
through they were in tears crying
because they couldn't do it and these
guys are the [ __ ] gangsters of
gangsters in the Navy you know I mean a
lot of these [ __ ] are like
Harvard grad as well as track stars like
they're just straight-up adrenaline
junkies like being the best is what
gives them a rush so then a lot of them
they're not even like blue-collar people
they're just crazy like Wall Street
[ __ ] that have to have that
amount of stimulation in order to
survive there's some crazy [ __ ]
I think if I was in the military I will
get awarded for being the best male
deliverer ever dude I get that [ __ ] done
on time mm-hmm no letter is [ __ ] off
time with me yeah then I get to number
one would be at least what country USA
that's what I was thinking what is it
the Green Berets in shield Army Rangers
Force Recon I'm kind of surprised that
the seals aren't number one
well according to this list it is back
from Britain the SAS bias article I'm
pretty sure the writer is from Great
Britain where the best yeah well what's
so special about the SAS
I'll read the little paragraphs but they
wrote under it what's this a group rated
higher than the seals indeed the British
special air service was created in 1941
as a force which could operate behind
German and Italian lines and support
resistant movements against the
occupation forces understandably the
force is made up of British military
personnel with the most coming from the
airborne forces physical requirements
are harsh and required a lot of marching
with full Pecha this culminates in a 40
mile march with a full pack that must be
finished in 20 hours candidates must
also be able to swim two miles in an
hour and a half god damn and run four
miles in 30 minutes four miles in 30
minutes
Wow so you got to be an amazing Runner
and amazing swimmer and you got a
sexy-ass accent that's crazy after this
you get dropped off in the jungle to
learn survival and navigational skills
for two it's you endorsed of a survival
practice the final test is a 36-hour
interrogation session meant to break the
cage will a day and a half the handful
who make it through this get transferred
to an operation force for further
training not convinced that this is
better than the seals it may help you to
know that the SAS is also trained by mi5
and mi6 fishery and intelligence
services to undertake counter espionage
operations it's like having a seal and
James Bond all rolled into one
is that what a Bear Grylls is ss Yosi
SAS sounds hella familiar I feel like he
was I guess the one up that they have
from Navy SEALs is the spy skills or
something that make sense then because
if you're combining like a CIA agent
with a Navy SEAL and then that's what
you get as SAS that's pretty gangster
I'm just sad that Force Recon isn't even
on the list was that the Marines one
yeah Force Recon is
the Marines but then all my Force Recon
friends they're always telling me making
fun of Navy SEALs because they train in
the same similar place and they're
saying that the Navy SEALs are only the
Navy SEALs because they're better
marketed they always do documentaries so
they always make fun of like how can
America's most secretive force be the
most well known they're saying we're
actually the more America secret force
so he served as a trainer I say yes yeah
she was a SAS instructor yeah
for what surviving in a wire probably
don't have to be a SAS before he's got
fast
yeah that's gangster yeah I don't know
he was that game I want to do like entry
levels of all of that interrogate me for
an hour
Oh five minutes John go for a little bit
you know like let's see let's just see
I'm not gonna survive any of that [ __ ]
to the badasses of the world listen I
remember from the documentary for the
Navy SEALs they just they chain you it's
like a ball and chain into the like the
middle of the ocean floor is [ __ ] he's
gonna swim up and undo that [ __ ] then
undo a mine a water mine and then
[ __ ] somehow survive hey guys thanks
for watching that last episode if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out up
here
[Music]